i knew a dude had llamas he had a
[ __ ] giant spread out in the cape and
uh he had [ __ ] llamas on his lawn and
[ __ ] dude i entered i did an entire tv
show about the leaping llama festival
you want to know the best part of it
is the the
the crux of the competition is how much
you can adorn your lana with gear like
put stuff on it cover its eyes and how
you can control it and you got to do a
sketch so this is in front of the whole
4-h for all the high schools around all
the parents all the kids
and i have no i'm not producing i'm just
a host and i go so what's me and llama
skit and they're like
rocky three i go oh it's my favorite
rocky club orlando and rocky i go i'm
rocky and they're like [ __ ] yeah you're
gonna come out the music will be playing
you get the llama llama's gonna look
just like mr t
so we get out
i get it to the llama and it was a white
llama they had to put it in black face
so it had like red lips oh my god
and they were like this part of the
competition is it pushing on his face
racist
it looks like a black face
knuckles
it was
my friend steve runella and his brother
matt use llamas when they hunt to carry
out the meat what are they dressing
trained llamas
they have these trained llamas they take
them into like a cargo van
they'll spit at you oh yeah just
that's a [ __ ] rude animal man